but she was the last person to see me
when felipe was with her all
night but got better fixed up she said that
she
was knowing that she went to sleep but
she was watching and
then she had a drink
and suddenly
without a drink they fought
like
other than a sleeping pill they had to have
someone among the guests
to signal them to turn off the power
just when I was alone upstairs
the work
will not be there please no really
no I don't want anyone
or peace we are close to pianos  they don't
pick up the airport
she's my sister laura much better
nothing to do with the previous one
[Music]
like dad
from grande
madrid- the bank were they in love
or not
[Applause]
[Music]
well
what  pass
the last car valve
I did not do anyone suspicious of having
someone among the guests
why
in the band by cell phone
and my daughter let me decide what to
do
antonio several houses commented
is not about unknown  gone
we have to be aware of your
surroundings
yes
[Music]
there is a way
you are getting too involved in this
matter
I trust your husband
[Music
] we had played everything they
are all
involved discovering that he does not know
now everyone knows
[Music]